during the whole flu thing that happened
I lost a lot of friends cuz I was very
vocal about how didn't think it was real
you know I'm very anti Force medicines
and then I'm also very anti-feminism and
I hate all of that and I'm genuinely so
passionate about it that I can't really
have friendships with people that
disagree with me on that because they
will get offended by just random things
that come out my mouth during the day if
I see a man that like I think is like
not attractive I'll be like he looks gay
do you know what I mean and that's like
not politically correct and that would
offend one of my old friends or if I'm
like oh you know I'm dating this guy and
like I really want to make him this like
nice pie or whatever friend would be
like you don't have to do that and then
we just have issues you know or if I'm
like oh I'd rather just do this for a
man and not have to like work like this
we're not going to get on me and a
girlfriend does that make sense